thank you to private internet access for
sponsoring today's episode Pia provides
a secure reliable VPN connection click
the link in the description below to
receive 82 off the first two years plus
four free months of free service
[Music]
it's pretty fun to watch organisms eat
in the micro Cosmos there's a whole
range of methods to enjoy you've got
single-celled organisms slowly absorbing
prey into their bodies through
phagocytosis rotifers whirling the crown
of cilia on their heads to get food into
their mouths and so many other
techniques that shape the life and death
of our invisible little friends and at
the core of this is a simple Universal
need energy energy stored chemically as
adenosine triphosphate or ATP that is
made from the breakdown of sugars and
fats in bacteria the production of ATP
happens at the cell surface membrane
with protons and electrons traveling at
the borders of the organism to drive the
creation of this Fuel and the process is
similar for eukaryotes except unlike
prokaryotes eukaryotes have organelles
specialized bodies inside of them to
carry out special chemical reactions and
there's even an organelle dedicated to
making ATP perhaps you have heard about
it the mitochondrion better known as the
PowerHouse of the cell
yes the PowerHouse of the cell the
origins of that phrase actually come
from a 1957 Scientific American article
written by Philip sikovitz that was
titled Powerhouse of the Cell It's Gone
on to become such a ubiquitous way to
describe the organelle that it even has
its own entry on knowyourmeem.com which
says quote the phrase is typically
mocked as an example of Impractical
information taught in public schools now
obviously we have Journey to the
microcosmos would never mock an
organelle especially one that is making
it possible for us to do just about
every single thing that we are doing at
this moment but we would like to take a
moment to maybe lightly question some
things
because is the mitochondria always the
powerhouses of the cell
no not for all eukaryotes and this
matters because it shapes the way we
understand the evolution of eukaryotes
there's a story about giant amoebas that
we have shared before but I want to talk
about in more detail today because when
you're talking about exceptions and
nuances to a commonly stated scientific
fact those details are fascinating
we also want to talk about it because we
would like to talk about diplomon ads
and to share again one of our favorite
historical observations of the
microcosmos
in the 17th century the original master
of microscopes Anthony Von lavenhoek
woke up with some less than ideal bowel
movements but lavenhook knew a good
opportunity when he saw one and he took
his watery sample to the microscope and
he wrote I have at times seen very
prettily moving and a molecules their
bodies were somewhat longer than Broad
and their belly which was flattened
provided with several feet with which
they've made such a movement through the
clear medium and globules that we might
fancy we saw a Pisa bed running up
against a wall
Clifford dobel lavenhook's biographer
took this description and matched it to
the medical knowledge available to him
in the early 20th century to diagnose
lavenhog with grd assis a disease born
out of a parasitic diplomona that
colonizes the human intestine now not
all diplomon ads are parasitic but they
are all just a little bit weird for one
they have two nuclei they also have
eight flagella trailing behind and
around them as they spin through the
microcosmos what makes diplomon ads
really weird though is that they do not
have mitochondria this puts diplomonads
into a small and exclusive club with a
handful of other eukaryotes these
organisms which scientists grouped
together into what they call the arcazoa
are anaerobic meaning they do not need
oxygen and might even prefer to live
away from it and that would explain why
they might not need mitochondria which
require oxygen to drive their reactions
but it does not EX explain how they got
this way so scientists worked with the
information they had at the time to come
up with an explanation an explanation
that would later be proven wrong they
reasoned that diplomon ads and their
fellow archazzoans got that way because
they just appeared a little too early
mitochondria are thought to have been
the result of an endosymbiotic event
where at one point in eukaryotic history
one cell engulfed a prokaryote but
instead of getting digested and consumed
this little prokaryote inside of another
cell became useful in a different way it
became an organelle and the diplomonads
scientists thought just missed out on
that big event except it turned out that
the arcazoa might have gotten in on the
mitochondria party they just also left
it losing their mitochondria to
Evolution's inventive ways in the
process the arcazoa were left with
genetic mementos from their former
organelle one of the unique facets of
mitochondria is that they have their own
DNA separate from the DNA of a cell's
nucleus but still able to instruct the
production of proteins necessary to the
mitochondria but what became clear is
that there wasn't nearly enough DNA to
encode for all those proteins in fact
the mitochondria only produce a small
fraction of the proteins they need
around 15 percent according to one
estimate the rest are encoded by DNA in
the nucleus transferred there at some
point by the endosymbiotic prokaryote
that would eventually become the
mitochondria this fact became important
when scientists realized that some of
these genes could be found in
diplomonads and their fellow arcazoa
genes that encoded proteins usually
associated with the mitochondria existed
in organisms that were thought to have
missed out on mitochondria entirely
which meant that perhaps they had not
missed out on mitochondria maybe they
had had mitochondria and they simply
traded them for a different way of life
and while there is always the
possibility that these genes could have
come from some other source that
alternative seemed increasingly unlikely
as it became clear that arcazoa have
organelles similar to mitochondria just
rewired to suit the chemical needs of
these anaerobic organisms in the
diplomon ads the organelle is called the
mitosome but curiously despite the
resemblance to mitochondria the mitosome
doesn't actually make ATP it's mostly
known to make clusters of iron and
sulfur used in many other cellular
functions including metabolism and
instead diplomon ads make ATP in their
cytosol the soupy mix that surrounds the
organelles other members of what was
once called the arcazoa have their own
mitochondria-like organelles capable of
making ATP and the result has been a
challenge to the story previously told
about them that these were early
progenitors of eukaryotes simpler than
what would come after
if anything it seems to be the opposite
these organisms very likely evolved with
mitochondria like their fellow
eukaryotes but they also evolved out of
them which means that there are so many
other questions to explore questions
about how organisms found their way and
survived in anaerobic conditions
questions about how mitochondria have
evolved and questions about what the
origins of eukaryotic life would have
looked like and as for the diplomon ad I
suppose we should say that these cytosol
is the PowerHouse of the cell and the
point is not to poke holes in a popular
biology aphorism taught to students the
mitochondria is the PowerHouse of the
cell for many many organisms including
you but when it comes to Evolution the
exceptions to the rules we think Define
us are the source of incredible Futures
written in mysterious and varied pasts
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the Unseen World
that surrounds us and thanks again to
private internet access for sponsoring
today's episode Pia provides a secure
reliable VPN connection I might be
asking yourself what's that well a VPN
is a virtual private Network it encrypts
your internet data and hides your IP
address keeping your information secure
and protected but it also allows you to
watch streaming content that may not be
available in your area so if you wanted
to watch a certain Seattle hockey team
play their hockey games but your sports
streaming service won't let you because
you're technically in the local viewing
area even though you live 500 miles away
from Seattle you can do that with Pia
private internet access works with all
major streaming services so you have
access to all your favorite content
anywhere in the world npia is available
for all platforms and one subscription
protects up to 10 devices at the same
time and pia has a next-gen server
infrastructure covering over 83
countries and each and every U.S state
you have a 30-day money-back guarantee
if you don't like the product or if it
doesn't meet your expectations and right
now Pia VPN is offering microcosmos
viewers their best deal yet an 82
discount and four free months when you
sign up using the link Pia VPN slash
microcosmos that link will be in the
description
thank you to all of the people who are
on screen right now they are our patreon
patrons and they allow us to uncover all
of these very bizarre mysteries about
life on this planet there are certain
folks who'd like to look a little deeper
and like to see things a little stranger
and these are definitely some of those
people and if you're interested in
supporting us so that we can make videos
like this the link is patreon.com
journey to micro
if you want to see more from our master
of microscopes James Weiss you can check
out jam and germs on Instagram and if
you want to see more from us
there's always a subscribe button
somewhere nearby
[Music]
[Applause]